hey hey hey hey Brendon what's up bro
long time no see man what bro
that's how we're doing it today like
you're ready to go and you don't want to
do that you two suck him off every day
as much you do want to do with Brendon
that's not sure don't say that what
cooler yeah I'll take you out what
happened to buh just happen in the
bathroom I'm 6 feet tall I've been
telling them forever your Heights in
your legs and you got a very short torso
you'll be like a frog you feel like I
was a human conversation and critic
criticism why would you quit a second
war what are you we can't even give a
guest of water listen what is your
problem already
oh you already like you're mad because
what's up brother because why do you man
are we recording are we are we live
we're on tonight I feel like you're
upset cuz they took the guest of the
year and then I never met this
[ __ ] I don't know anything about
the other one and I feel like you're say
cuz steal took a guess the year and then
your brother who never sends me gear
what's his [ __ ] name Jay Jay you [ __ ]
let's call him out again Jay Schwab you
you got your [ __ ] t-shirts you big
brown Jay go [ __ ] yourself Jay nobody
coming on this show I'm a three-time
guest of the air cannon get [ __ ] water
can't get a [ __ ] water
look at that thing there no [ __ ] free
t-shirt Jay god damn it it's ridiculous
I'm not no [ __ ] UFC fighter jail [ __ ]
and walk off right now
in the Jade yeah Jay and Jay let's play
hoops too Jay I know you want you like
to do you think you sitting courtside
Saran three you think you're gonna beat
the [ __ ] big three courtside you
[ __ ] you're gonna be getting me
popcorn you little prick August 26 you
[ __ ] is Jay gonna be there he might even
[ __ ] intern that day you [ __ ] you we
getting the churl here you bet your bet
is this you and [ __ ] Jay come clean
miles that way you get out of there two
hours I don't want to see your [ __ ]
faces more than two hours mayweather
wins you and jay show up you where I am
Rappaport stereo podcast t-shirts you
were my mom that last row you gave me
the gringo I don't think Ringo mandingo
I love that shirt
not the gringo thing the gringo means
you know it's the fighter and the kid
but it back to being Rappaport and the
fighter because Bryan Callen a 50 year
old Bryan Callen couldn't make it run a
little bit well Bryan Travolta and we
say the Travolta a serious [ __ ] here
is he late and let's remind that the
folks you tell me if I'm wrong with your
Bobby Lee's and your other guys your
bluff what's the highest rated fighter
in the kid episode ever
I'd have to look but probably one with
you on it no no no no no when I guest
hosting oh yes that was a big one yes
that a big one and let's say you you
wouldn't know cuz that was like last
year's last year yeah but but ever that
was the biggest either in the kid
episode ever of 2016 well mm you had to
gone up well I would hook or okay so I'm
pretty sure it's safe to say that the
episode that Bryan Callen wasn't there
it did what it did well yeah which which
makes you think like this like a [ __ ]
dead weight I win this [ __ ] boy v when
the fifth year ago fifty old foot boy
yeah man [ __ ] [ __ ] man on the other side
of his life who shows up late for guests
see that means that getting taken for
granted the other thing is we had to
switch it right like to 9:30 big [ __ ]
do you know I'm saying I'm saying that
we did that for you cuz I know you got a
busy day shooting and then he's saying
oh I'm something with the Goldbergs
Callen you're so full of [ __ ]
who you know it [ __ ] up showing up
late today
hey it's okay we're take I'm good it's
higher that's just a [ __ ] fact the
ratings for the episode are gonna be
high and then when he comes
Leto we put him in the [ __ ] guessing
yeah my house like a little guest yeah
might have to we put him like like like
he's like the guy over there like we
guys we're like we talking me like no no
we're not finish
[ __ ] and then we'll go back you you want
to sit in your seat brain well you know
what dude the whole podcast for me is
kind of ruined now let's switch lets you
guys want to switch I feel like look at
how he's sitting well I'm
but look I'm sad I'm insulted here's a
green shirt with a purple sweater on
like the Joker but I dig it be do you
like it I like that no I like it by the
way you know that I don't have more my
awesome new boots it's cuz it's raining
Brendan bought me some two boots did you
know they probably cost a million
dollars one mil were they like like from
the the the NSYNC collection no these
because I see you got no you're you're
pretty low-key they cuz I know it's
raining are you but like you don't have
any ripple gene get out of my [ __ ]
seats which I'm not mad at your roots of
fight was that Mike Tyson hoodie was
that Muhammad Ali hey maybe he kind of
you can you name the first podcast I
ever did the purse first podcast you
ever did this is why he's not a good
listener was probably a fighter and oh
no no it was is the now-defunct Bryan
Callen show right and you said then I
said I said if you could do a [ __ ]
podcast [ __ ] I can definitely do it
really made me into a trap right now and
you know what he said in the middle of
the podcast we're doing it and this is
on Saturday my hotel room and he goes
like this in the middle and nobody could
see it because I guess in the middle of
my answering question he goes why are
you not wearing pants right it doesn't
make any sense and now you're taking her
shirt off people actually thought I was
I had to tweet back I was like that was
the very first podcast I did and after
that yeah do you know I was like [ __ ] if
they're paying this guy a [ __ ] nickel
to [ __ ] me you his [ __ ] his nonsense
lies in exaggerating the facts about
reading things that I got marina [ __ ]
my reader yeah any brains about life
anything
Google's not reading like [ __ ] like
cliff notes aren't real highlight area I
think you can now Google the cliff notes
that's true I thought that it was just
gonna be you and me there and he'll tell
you I was like oh
here today I thought was just hey wait a
minute no I know neither when you show
that was I think your phone up and text
somebody no good [ __ ] sport oh man
that's not quiet as a dermatologist I
have a point of view on [ __ ]
basketball and I disagree with what you
guys are saying and and also is you guys
are forget about the self and it's also
cool because um hey man that's my wallet
oh oh my man my man we've already
started but what excuse me you didn't
have any [ __ ] issues you sit down in
the guest seat sit down to the guest
seat sit that we showers not happy man
your legs started sit down in the guess
seat look tell us what your issues are
and you're gonna make I come on come on
come on three TV shows it okay as you
know right okay and sometimes scheduling
can be you okay so welcome I sitting in
this chair for cuz you today you can't
just pull your way into my tell you
you're bigger yeah I don't know how I'm
gonna get you out you're a guest today
where's the camera this is the kind of
[ __ ] that this is this is I've never
been more disrespected in my life I've
had a rough day I had to work scheduling
shoes I got a live show in San Francisco
and I have to shoot the same day okay
what was your ap rapper time I like
how's the schedule good out like yeah
what was the schedule onset a lot yet
Travolta like tell me what this guy [ __ ]
on my Mannie cuz he doesn't work on me
anymore no you know what I do is set be
when they go your call times nine it's
not like getting calm like I listen I
got this thing like yeah they don't care
what's your schedule by the way by the
way you're hurting yourself by showing
up because I wonder where I reminded be
shop that the highest rated fighter in
the kid episode is what what episode I
don't want if you see it's who are you
flip tone for what you do the numbers I
don't you do the run the numbers but the
highest-rated fighter in the kids
without it you don't come on my podcast
and start to talk about how you get
higher ratings rap test you rap I'm not
here rappers take it Oh what am i doing
you sit there in the guest spot for a
little bit yeah get out of my seat so
tell us why you're late and then we'll
see if alien work I can't
grab you in Hollywood awhile so you tell
me if I don't think [ __ ] me today
what you tell me the [ __ ] my Karan's
resumes like this it's a nice solid
resume it's building it's big but but
you busy man but you're talking about
like no yeah then you go like that it's
like it's like it's like if we if we if
I pull down my loaf I'd be like yeah
Bryan Callen and then there's like it's
like there's a little noise Bryan Callen
puts his loaf on the table like that and
then the gringo mandingo puts it it's
like you kept the cracking you caught
the grand you caught although the heavy
no busting okay so what explain heavy
loaf
so so the issue becomes when you get I'm
supposed to shoot on Tuesday when rain
happens and it's outdoor shoot they got
to move everything into Thursday promise
I got to be in San Francisco on Thursday
and all of a sudden script change and
stuff like that and I go here's a
problem why are you late I go you got it
you got a window we got to work the
window out whether I gotta come in later
today there's all kinds of scheduling
issues that I just had to deal with okay
I was in the parking lot I was in the
parking right on my phone like this
watch watch this and another thing
another thing you'll do is change the
schedule that's how I talk to Hollywood
hey Michael rocky hosting the Grammys in
purple crushed velvet correct jackets
and you're talking about do you say no
to anything I turned on the [ __ ]
Grammys and I was like that guy no not
my guy with a purple crushed jacket no
sitting there talking about fashion but
then I said to myself number one number
one this makes total sense because it's
like a straight tough guy you are about
as fashion-forward like you I'm
surprised you're not wearing some like
it's annoying isn't it
I mean today's this is normal but like
jeans and [ __ ] like this is right yeah
normally I crush you let you do and I've
seen this [ __ ] terrible those Gucci
boots with the Bison yes I last time
ozoni wore that got anyone talking to me
like the gucci boots with the buckle or
dope right oh no I was wearing my Saint
Laurent boots cuz you and I I know I
know and they're like they're probably
like I think they're $1,500 no bogies a
hell of an ass Steph Curry's one
he's an athlete stuff great probably
yeah shut your [ __ ] or there's our
GoDaddy fine bottles Lee and sucking
side off noticin omelette you guys
[ __ ] omelette you [ __ ] okay go
Chinese belly it's super disrespectful
man I'm not a shot yeah um yo you got
[ __ ] on the bottom of your shoes that's
not that's gone
are you got tired Brian Brian Oprah
not tired not tired no I have a backpack
of energy I have what's called an extra
backpack of stamina brother and on a
forced march well if you're [ __ ] way
behind and this is me oh my lord
Mike come on Mike Mike I want you to
keep your eyes on my belt loop don't
take them off my belt loop
I want you smelling my [ __ ] to hold
up this hill and then finally I take my
belt and I wrap it around your [ __ ]
head and I tug you I dragged you up
because you're complaining the whole
[ __ ] night you're just lazy dog leash
ooh I got it and then the other thing is
because of your skin is not built for
the Sun no you're you're a [ __ ]
bright your tomato tomahto
you're a tomato mater your tomato
protect you against sunstroke and your
lungs exam outing and your feet and
everything else just don't have the
stamina rap I want you smelling my
[ __ ] the whole way I grab you by the
ears and look you in the eye go yeah
that's my bad
oh boy let's do this keep the hat on I
got a I got a fashion you a hat you a
hat out of [ __ ] palm fronds right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]